[Music]
foreign
exploding wildfires engulfing Canada
Alberta on edge is towering Flames inch
closer to town to break records year
after year after year
I I believe speaks quite loudly how a
firefighter
just sparking concern for the season
ahead
of town
we're in Miami ahead of the former U.S
president's court appearance what Trump
wants from his supporters the Airbnb
effect on affordable housing people have
been evicted and then the Land part puts
these places on Airbnb makes you know a
double or triple and what were you doing
at 12. hi my name is Anthony Patricia
Dennis I'm a student in the honors
Bachelor's in biomedical science meet
Canada's youngest University grad
global national with para Nasser
good evening and thanks for joining us
tonight we begin with those raging
wildfires burning across Canada but
especially in Alberta where the return
of hot and dry conditions has caused the
situation to spiral one of the worst
affected areas is the town of Edson west
of Edmonton the fire engine closer and
closer to the community has been labeled
a beast by the town's mayor and it's
exploded in size growing 55 percent in
just 24 hours
this phone video shows one resident's
daring Escape towering Flames are less
than two kilometers away from homes
forcing people to flee for the second
time in just a month
there are more than 75 wildfires in
Alberta and approximately a third of
them are out of control and more than 11
000 people across that Province are now
displaced Erica Vela has our top story
tonight
Alberta struggling to cope as wildfires
inch closer replacing on the edge and if
you can't even sleep sometimes because
you're you're wondering what's next in
parts of brazo County an evacuation
alert has been issued residents must be
prepared to leave their homes on 30
minutes notice the smoke was so thick
like literally you had trouble breathing
there are 77 active wildfires in Alberta
and in Quebec we have 131 wildfires
active The Province taking an offensive
approach with help from reinforcements
but it's still not safe for evacuees to
return home we have discussion with
those communities and when it's going to
be safe enough they will be able to go
back this is absolutely an unprecedented
season things started early in all parts
of Canada there are over 400 active
fires burning across the country more
than 200 of them considered out of
control we have 4.7 million hectares
that have been burnt already in the
country
with the early start to the Wildfire
season experts say it will have
detrimental impacts on Wildlife I expect
a lot of species are losing their
reproduction for the year that all the
birds that are investing right now
things like snowshoe hares that have
their first litter of Offspring right
now
those babies will not be able to escape
from the fires Hodges says it's likely
the fires will cause Wildlife
populations to decline some will die
some loss of reproduction this year the
others will be displaced I'm especially
concerned for threatened and endangered
species that rely on these mature
forests and if we are losing habitat for
them now
that's going to make maintenance and
then recovery for these populations and
species more difficult work is underway
to suppress the fires Across the Nation
but with the end of wildfire season
still months away many are hoping Mother
Nature will bring a welcome reprieve
what we need is we need some rain like
we needed yesterday irkavella Global
News Toronto
across the border in BC cooler
conditions and shifting winds are
helping fire Crews gain the upper hand
in the community of Tumblr Ridge about 2
400 people living in the mining town
were told to leave on Thursday last week
Romina Daya is in Tumbler Ridge for us
tonight Romina
for a Tumblr Ridge is still standing but
it's a ghost town ribbons on houses
confirmation residents have evacuated
while it's blue skies here today and the
winds are calmer the fire threat is
still very real
the fire is roughly four kilometers away
from Tumblr Ridge slightly cooler
temperatures and a shift in the wind
away from town is giving front line
firefighters time to lay fire breaks and
pound the forest with water this plan of
attack is expected to continue today as
long as the weather holds we're doing
everything in our power to keep this
fire information in their Community
2 400 residents were ordered to leave
their homes Thursday after the fire blew
up but many have refused to go
Marcel Brodeur a former firefighter
keeping watch over his community and
sending updates to worried friends
border laser focused on the Ridgeline
behind his home you can't see it but the
fire is Raging on the other side
right now we're looking really good and
um
yeah I think I I got a feeling we're
going to be okay
anxious residents are wondering when or
if they'll be able to return home the
evacuation order still stands however
the district is issuing temporary entry
passes for legitimate reasons for
example if you have livestock to feed or
other essential Services Farah
roomina Daya in Tumblr Ridge BC thanks
for your coverage tonight
now we go to the U.S where Donald Trump
is preparing for his arraignment in
Miami on Tuesday as the first former
president to be federally indicted he
faces dozens of severe charges for over
a hundred classified National Security
files he allegedly kept after leaving
office
[Music]
still rallying behind Trump who's long
called the investigation a Witch Hunt
and remains committed to his campaign to
retake the presidency in the 2024
election
our Jackson prosco is in Miami with more
on the preparations ahead of Tuesday and
he joins us now from there Jacksonville
can we expect
pharah Donald Trump has called on his
supporters to Rally outside the
courthouse here in Miami on Tuesday to
protest what he calls the boxes hoax but
the fact is the indictment unsealed by
special counsel Jack Smith on Friday is
deadly serious and poses significant
legal Peril for the former president
those boxes of classified documents
recovered from Trump's Florida home
allegedly contained U.S nuclear secrets
and Intelligence on foreign Nations some
of the documents are so sensitive that
their level of classification is
actually classified itself Trump
returned to the campaign Trail on
Saturday where he railed against the
special counsel and the justice
department claiming the whole
investigation is politically motivated
but if you want a sense of How High the
legal Stakes are just take a listen to
Trump's former Attorney General Bill
Barr a longtime defender of trump in
many other investigations
if even half of it is true then he's
toast I mean it's a it's a pretty it's a
very detailed indictment and it's very
very damning and this idea of presenting
Trump as a victim here a victim of a
Witch Hunt is ridiculous now much like
we saw in New York when Trump was
indicted on state level charges security
outside the courthouse remains a real
concern except here there's an added
element because Florida is very much
Trump country it's much easier for his
supporters to get here and make their
voices heard some of Trump's political
allies are going even further and
they're essentially calling for violence
or in some cases even Civil War that
being said the Secret Service says no
extra precautions are being taken for
Trump's visits it's expected he'll turn
himself over to the U.S Marshals for
processing ahead of his arraignments on
Tuesday afternoon
far
Jackson Brosco in Miami for us thanks
Jackson
prime minister Justin Trudeau is on his
way home after Saturday's surprise visit
to Ukraine where he and Deputy Prime
Minister Krista Freeland met with
President velodimir zielinski announcing
more money to help the people of Ukraine
according to the United Nations there
have been more than 23 000 civilian
casualties in Ukraine since Russia
invaded off that number more than 8 000
have been killed and nearly 15 000
injured and now we're learning the
Russian forces actually fired at rescue
boats in the wake of that devastating
Dam collapse in major flooding killing
three people but tonight as Redmond
Shannon reports Ukraine says it's
gaining ground in a new
counter-offensive claiming to have
retaken a village occupied by Russia
in a war where the two sides dispute the
most basic of facts prisoner swaps
somehow continue to happen almost a
hundred Russians freed by Ukraine Sunday
with a similar number of Ukrainian
troops heading home in the opposite
direction one other rare area of
agreement is that both sides say the
flood waters are now receding somewhat
although there the consensus ends Kiev
and Moscow accuse each other of blowing
up the kokova dam
the Ukrainian governor of her son claims
Russian troops fired at three boats of
evacuees killing three people and
injuring more such dangers in a war zone
weighed up against the ongoing risk of
disease the water unsafe to drink for
humans and animals conservationist
Katarina feluta says it could take years
or decades for some ecosystems to
the consequences will be for our
children or grandchildren just as we are
the ones now experiencing the
consequences of the Chernobyl disaster
to the East Ukraine claims its
counter-offensive has liberated a
village in the southern donbass it would
be the first settlement retaken since
President Vladimir zielinski signaled
the start of the much anticipated
operation during prime minister Justin
Trudeau's visit on Saturday
Moscow meanwhile is just as eager to
trumpet battle victories defense
minister Sergey shoigu decorating
soldiers for the kremlin's claims of
taking out some of Ukraine's German and
U.S made tanks Russia also says it
foiled an attempted attack on a black
sea Navy vessel by amphibious drones the
information War rages on beside the real
one with little end in sight to either
Redmond Shannon Global News London
shortage at the worst time coming up the
alarming reality around retention and
recruitment across Canada
foreign
to our Wildfire coverage now given the
fact that Canada's on track to record
the most severe Wildfire season ever
seen it's all hands on deck right now
but it's an uphill battle because
despite hundreds of personnel from other
countries lending a helping hand a
shortage of firefighters across this
country is Raising concern for the rest
of the season and as Joe scarpelli
reports the burning question is does
Canada have enough people to keep
communities safe going forward
months before Wildfire season started
the Canadian Association of Fire Chiefs
warned of a concerning Trend the number
of both career and volunteer
firefighters is going down Ken McMullen
is the president of the association
there's definitely a shortfall there's
no doubt about it Canada is burning
through hundreds of thousands of
kilometers of land every day nearly 5
million hectares so far this year
McMullen says Canada is battling the
fires with 30 000 fewer firefighters
than there were in the year of the Fort
McMurray Wildfire you think about that
amount of work that we're doing today
you think about all of the fires that
are in our communities today we're we're
tackling those with 30 000 less today
than we did in 2016. that's a
significant issue roughly 70 percent of
Canadian firefighters are volunteers
most of them have other jobs making it
difficult to strike a balance when
dealing with lengthy fire events if you
have Wall fire impractical Community it
is 24 7 for weeks if not days if not
weeks on end where people need to be
there to doing that work I made calls
for better training and increased tax
incentives for volunteers prime minister
Justin Trudeau says Canada has enough
resources to cover the summer but the
government is developing contingency
plans if things get worse but some are
already coming up with their own
long-term contingency plans
take falgoni Saskatchewan for example
where the Aging volunteer fire
department like so many others is
looking for young blood young blood that
may seem less inclined to gear up we run
what's called a junior firefighter
program we bring kids in ranging from as
young as 14 years old hopefully we get
them hooked at a young age then when
they turn 18 we can actually start
utilizing
um The Young Ones despite some success
the chief admits the firefighting
industry needs a lot more attention not
just in his town but in communities
across the country
Joe scarpelli Global News
ahead the Ripple effects of Airbnb
term residence
if you're planning summer travel you've
probably noticed that the cost of hotels
has gone through the roof this year and
it's prompted many people to look at
more affordable options like airbnbs now
the industry has come roaring back after
taking a back seat during the pandemic
but it's one of many factors
contributing to the current housing
crisis and gaviola has more on what's
being labeled the Airbnb effect
with a return of travel Comes The Return
of demand for airbnbs pulling thousands
of units from the long-term rental
market into short-term rentals squeezing
already unaffordable cities like Toronto
and Vancouver the empirical evidence is
very clear that both before the pandemic
and now after the pandemic the
short-term rentals are playing a major
role in making housing less affordable
people have been evicted and then the
landlock puts these places on Airbnb
makes you know double or triple the
amount of money a month than they did
renting to a long-term attendant There
are rules in Canada's two most expensive
cities to crack down on so-called super
hosts who own multiple units and rent
them on Home Sharing platforms siphoning
housing stock for profit data firm air
DNA says regulation has made a
difference most people respect the law
and as a result when you enact these
regulations yeah it really slows the the
growth in listings and Airbnb tells
Global News it works closely with policy
makers to ensure rules are followed the
San Francisco go-based company says most
of its users are renting space within
their home to help make ends meet in
Canada 53 of our hosts say they use
income from hosting to cover the cost of
living uh 47 States help them stay in
their homes and yet the data shows that
there are ways to get around laws
a fire in Montreal in March killed seven
people six were staying in illegal
Airbnb units prompting the province of
Quebec to look at imposing tough new
rules on Home Sharing platforms that
come with financial penalties hopefully
it will set an example you know for
other jurisdictions across Canada so
that you know a tragedy like this won't
repeat itself and as long as there's a
lot of money to be made people are going
to be really incentivized to figure out
ways to make that money and that means
that governments need to act you know
strongly Airbnb isn't the only Factor
juicing housing affordability but it's
an easy target for lawmakers and gaviola
Global News Toronto
[Music]
we meet the youngest Canadian to get a
University degree her extraordinary
Journey next
[Music]
right now in almost every Province crews
are working to put out wildfires that
threaten communities while smoke creates
dystopian scenes far from the front
lines on Friday I had a conversation
with the forestry and climate change
expert Dr Patrick James in Toronto's
High Park we talked about what's fueling
these fires and the future of Canadian
forests
Dr James we've had wildfires before you
know especially in western Canada but
these fires are hotter the smoke is
going higher into the atmosphere
is this linked to climate change
I would say most definitely there's a
consequence of climate change on our
weather patterns including temperature
pressure precipitation we've had the
third warmest May on record there are
some exceptional temperatures in the
ocean which lead to these higher
temperatures and more energy in the
system and in general fires are this
this the result of the interactions
between fuels ignitions and weather
and so we've had these incredibly dry
hot conditions the fuels are very dry
and then with sources of ignitions from
things like thunderstorms we get that
Confluence of factors that are resulting
in these huge clusters of very damaging
fires it is a spring Wildfire season
though so is that rare to see this
during the Spring I mean I guess most of
the provinces in in Canada have are on
fire right now right yeah it is unusual
to have this much fire activity this
early in the season I believe Quebec has
exceeded its recent records an area
burned and it's only within June and
this is the consequence of these really
warm dry weeks we've had in the spring
before the vegetation has leafed out in
the forest there's just very dry
conditions you know vegetation holds
water vegetation on the landscape can
temper the effects of a fire but in the
spring before that happens these fuels
are dry and very very susceptible to
fire how do we prevent a a Slave Lake or
Fort McMurray when we're seeing these
fires right it's a it's a difficult
question I'd say investment in emergency
preparedness
education there are some options
involving fuel mitigation around
communities or resources so I think you
know thinking about this through the
lens of climate change and our
obligations to reduce atmospheric CO2
concentrations and realizing that there
is this direct link between carbon
dioxide emissions and temperature and
heat and of course Wildfire regimes is
this our new reality yeah I think a lot
of people would say so
um we continue to have record-breaking
years in terms of both fire and weather
so you know and it doesn't seem like
it's just a one-off right so it seems
like an aha moment right now well yeah
I'd say so and and I would hope people
would realize that this is this is the
new Norm these extremes are the new
normal if you were to just have one
extreme year every once in a while we
could attribute that to variation
natural variation and chance but to
break records year after year after year
um I I believe speaks quite loudly and
uh yeah I think we need to brace
ourselves for more extreme fire weather
mega fires than than fewer
when we look at at these plants in this
vegetation I mean it has been here for
for eons what are the long-term effects
of these of these type of wildfires yeah
and I think I think that's a really
interesting question
um the the trees the forest they have an
evolutionary history of dealing with
fire and so a really interesting
question is are these fires happening in
such a way with such a severity that
they may exceed the capacity of these
systems to recover and so are we going
to see uh expected regeneration
trajectories are we going to see
wildlife able to respond to these and so
I mean this is this link between climate
change and disturbances Wildlife Forest
regeneration the sort of complexity that
we try to address and it's not a simple
not a simple answer all right Dr Patrick
James thanks so much for sharing your
expertise with us thank you very much
there are fictional sitcoms about kids
like Anthea Grace Patricia Dennis here
Doogie Hauser young Sheldon but this is
real life and they had completed
kindergarten at the age of two she
started University at nine and last
night she graduated
hi my name is Anthony Grace Patricia
Dennis I'm a student in the honors
Bachelor's in biomedical science but my
research area is in neuroscience and
Thea why is beyond her years is just 12
years old here's a photo of the preteen
grad crossing the stage at the
University of Ottawa last night in fact
she's the youngest Canadian ever to
graduate from a university in biomedical
science no less and Thea completed a
40-page thesis about the relationship
between the brain and the hand for right
versus left-handed people and the best
part she's not done yet she plans to
pursue a postgraduate degree after the
summer break
congratulations to you and Thea and we
can't wait to follow your journey hope
you get to rest during the summer that's
global national for this Sunday night
I'm foreign Oster thanks for spending
part of your evening with us tonight's
your Canada is Bracebridge Ontario until
next time take care of yourselves and
take care of each other good night
[Music]
thank you